we knew each other back in the day when
neither one of us had much to do we
weren't very busy we shared an apartment
years ago and neither one of us had a
gig and now you've got like 65 gigs
you're in the new Star Wars right yeah
but not anything that anyone would know
well I want to make it known that in
addition to these other projects you're
in the Star Wars movie that came out not
long I truly am I went to London to film
rise of Skywalker yeah yes but I did it
you know I'm friends with JJ Abrams you
know and Michelle reg1 my former
assistant produce the movie my assistant
yeah dose the movie anyhow I went there
for hours of makeup we see you in the
makeup is that okay the picture of you
in the makeup there you are so you sat
there you fly to London yes four hours
of makeup it's gonna be very exciting
you're gonna be in the JJ Abrams
directed rise of Skywalker I knew I had
no lines cuz he does that I'll sneak
people in but I thought maybe I get you
know worst case scenario three four
seconds yeah it may be a second if even
that I think it's like 2/10 of a second
but what happened where I went oh oh so
where are you anyway are you in the
foreground I'm in like right before they
go off for their final fight there's a
whole speech and they talk about stuff
and I'm there I'm the only alien in the
Z you think that could have stayed on me
for a second I got scared for a toy
no I am NOT the only person never say
they were angrily yeah I got scared for
a toy you think they want you know a
little bit of recognition nope
so wait did you ask JJ about this did
you show me oh my still in it yep you're
still in it right didn't tell me for a
tenth of a second so I wrote by the way
there's how crazy Star Wars people are
oh my god
so I put on my Instagram post that JJ
Burres has ruined my life and my career
and I called I called him dream
destroyer hastag dream come clearly
joking yeah joe yeah and these people
did a reddit page about our JJ's ruin
Mike they're lucky thrown Star Wars hero
Jeff Garlin
[Applause]